a local hospital recently conducted a
blood drive where they collected a total
of 80 pints of blood from donors the
hospital was hoping to collect a total
of eight gallons of blood from the drive
did they meet their goal how much more
or less than their gold at the hospital
collect so really they collected 80
pints we just need to figure out how
many gallons that is and then say well
is that going to be more or less than
eight gallons so we have we start with
80 80 pints and we could take it step by
step you may or may not know how many
pints there are per gallon so let's just
go straight to quarts first and then
from quarts we can go to gallons but if
you know right from the get-go how many
pints there are per gallon you could go
there so let's do convert this to quarts
so we've 80 pints so what are we going
to multiply or divided by to get the
courts well one way to think about it
you're going from a smaller unit pints
to a larger unit so you're going to have
less of that larger unit so you're going
to divide you're going to this number is
going to be smaller when it goes into
quarts and it's going to be smaller than
by a factor of two because you have two
pints per quart so you're going to have
you're not going to multiply by two
you're not gonna have more courts you
can divide by two so you could say times
1/2 this is the same thing as dividing
by two and we'll make sure that the
units work out we have one quart one
quart for every two pints or you could
view this as two pints per quart or one
half of a quart per pint either way the
units work out and you're essentially
taking 80 and dividing by two or
multiplying by one half and you get 40
quarts and I want to make sure that your
brain does it both ways because when
you're just doing it you don't have
paper you don't have the units around
you should just think you know hey 80
pints there's two pints per quart I'm
gonna have half as many quarts I'm gonna
have 40 quarts but when problems get a
little more complicated it is nice to
make sure that the unit's cancel out in
this way so that you know okay
one quart is two pints pints in the
denominator pints in the numerator
cancel them out I just left with quarts
and eighty times 1/2 which is 40 so we
have 40 quarts now 40 quarts and now we
can convert this to gallons we know that
there are 4 quarts per gallon or that
one gallon has 4 quarts and once again
we're going to go from
smaller unit to a larger unit to gallons
so it's we know there's a factor for
difference since you're going to a
larger unit your brain should say hey
I'm gonna divide by four I'm gonna have
I'm going to have a factor of four fewer
gallons because the larger unit and to
make sure the units work out you just
remember well we have a quartz up here
in the numerator you're gonna want two
quarts down here in the denominator and
you have any what we care about
converting into gallons and one gallon
is four quarts and this will work out
the courts will cancel out and notice
you're also dividing by four forty times
one half of sorry forty times one fourth
is the exact same thing as 40 divided by
four which makes sense we're going into
a larger unit so 40 times one fourth is
10 and the units left are gallons so the
80 pints of blood of blood that the
hospital collected is 10 gallons their
goal was only 8 gallons their goal was
only 8 gallons so did they meet their
goal yes they met their goal how much
more or less than their gold at the
hospital collect well their goal was 8
they collected 10 they collected two two
extra gallons two extra gallons then
their goal